لاعبو الجولف الألمان على الخضر الإسبانية
يأتون إلى مايوركا كل عام أكثر من أربعة ملايين زائر ألماني.السياحة هي
حجر الأساس لاقتصاد Mayorkas
ويقول المسؤولون هنا إن 97 ٪ من
سياحة الجزر تعتمد على الزوار من أوروبا
وخاصة الألمان مثل العديد من
وجهات العطلات التي
يهددها الوباء  تدمير موسم الصيف في Mayorkas
حتى لو تم تخفيف قيود السفر
، يقول مالك الدورة ديرك
ديغلر ، المخاوف الجوية والناس يبقون أعتقد
في اليوم الآخر الذي كنت أتحدث فيه مع
زوجين من أعضاء نادينا
وقالوا لي جيدًا إننا نرغب في ذلك  انطلق ،
نريد الذهاب في إجازات ، لكننا نفضل
الذهاب إلى المكان الذي يمكننا الوصول إليه
بالسيارة لأنه عندما يحدث شيء ما ،
فإننا نأخذ سيارتنا
ونقودها إلى المنزل ، قتل kovat 19 ما يقرب من 30 ألف شخص
في إسبانيا ولكن معظمهم في المدن الكبرى في
لم تتأثر مدريد وبرشلونة مايوركا
نسبيًا مع تخفيف قيود الإصابة بعدد أقل بكثير
، ومن حيث فيروس كورونا ، فإن الجزيرة
تشبه في الواقع المستوى المنخفض.
معدلات nfection في ألمانيا بلدي Orca هو
المنزل الثاني للعديد من المشاهير الألمان
بما في ذلك عارضة الأزياء الشهيرة كلوديا شيفر
ولديها فيلا في هذا الجانب من
الجزيرة وفي الواقع طالب أكثر من مائة من
مالكي منازل العطلات الألمانية
بالحق في العودة إلى هنا ولكن هل هناك
طريقة لذلك  افعل ذلك بأمان ، نعم تقول ميكايلا
ليو بارتون ، مؤلف مشارك في اقتراح جديد
يقول إنه سيعمل في الاتحاد الأوروبي وخارجه ،
كلنا نحب الشواطئ الجميلة
ولكننا نريد جميعًا أن نكون آمنين
إذا كانت هناك مجموعة من العدوى
تفشت للتو بينما نحن  إن قضاء إجازتنا
على الشاطئ هنا ما قد يبدو
مثل المناطق الخضراء التي تم التحقق منها والتي تحتوي على
الفيروس تحت السيطرة من شأنه أن يسمح
بالسفر المجاني فيما بينها ، يمكن للزائر البافاري
السفر مباشرة إلى Orca الخاصة بي حتى لو كانت
الحدود الوطنية مغلقة للاختبار
وتتبع سعة المستشفى وغيرها من
المعايير الصارمة  يجب أن تكون
معتمدة من الاتحاد الأوروبي ويجب على الدول إثبات
قدرتها على الحفاظ على المناطق الخضراء آمنة
ومعزولة عن المناطق الحمراء حيث
قد لا يزال الفيروس ينتشر  تأمل مسؤولة السياحة روزانا ماريا أن تعمل الخطة إذا كان ما سيحدث إذا كانت هناك قائمتان في نفس الوضع كما نعتقد أنهما آمنان لنا وآمنان بالنسبة لهما ، تحرص الشواطئ في جميع أنحاء إسبانيا على إظهار قدرتها على ضمان سلامة الزائر في ابتكار التطبيقات لحجز مساحة بطانية على الشاطئ ، ووضع حصى رملية لفرض قيود السفر للمسافات الاجتماعية ، لا تزال سارية ، ولكن حتى تتم الموافقة على الخطة ، سيتعين على الشواطئ الانتظار لفترة أطول قليلاً ، من الجيد أن ترى وجهك كنت قد مررت به كثيرًا في في الشهرين الماضيين ، يسعدني حقًا أن أراكم تفتحون مرة أخرى ، شكرًا لكم ، إن الاتصال بالمجتمع أقوى بكثير مما كنا نعتقد أن جيمس شجرز يدير مطبخ إستر في منطقة لاس فيغاس للفنون ، إنه من سكان فيغاس ومرشح لجيمس بيرد لعام 2020 التقيت به أثناء تغطيته لأحداث فيغاس والمساهمة في منشورات مثل أشجار CNN Travel ، تم إغلاق مطعمه لمدة شهرين تقريبًا بسبب جائحة فيروس كورونا الذي أعاد افتتاحه للتو في مايو و
لقد كان يقوم ببعض
الأعمال الثابتة إلى حد ما بقدر ما هو مسموح به بعد
أن دفع الطاولات بعيدًا عن بعضها البعض وذهب
إلى الحجوزات فقط ، ما
نبحث عنه هو السماح للأشخاص
بالراحة مع أي شيء سيكون هذا
الوضع الطبيعي أو المؤقت الجديد
لفترة طويلة  في أوائل شهر
يونيو ، ستبدأ كازينوهات المدينة في اتباع نفس
مواعيد الافتتاح المذهلة لأنها
تكثف عملياتها مرة أخرى ، فيجاس
جاهزة لاستقبال الزوار مرة أخرى في المدينة ،
فقد لا تكون نفس لاس فيجاس التي
تتذكر أن العالم قد تغير وأن فيجاس قد تغيرت.
التغيير معها ، لذا نعم ، ستكون الأشياء
مختلفة قليلاً عندما نفتح مرة أخرى
على الأقل لفترة من الوقت فيغاس
جديدة للواقع الجديد لتوفير الهروب ،
ستكون أشياء مختلفة إلى حد ما متعلقة
بالحشود لن تكون متاحة ،
وهذا هو ستيف هيل الذي  يرأس مؤتمر لاس
فيغاس وسلطة الزوار ،
وهي المنظمة المكلفة بتسويق
كل جنوب نيفادا على حسابهم ،
زار أكثر من 42 مليون شخص L  نظرًا لأن
Vegas العام الماضي من هذا الرقم 6.6
مليون جاءت للمؤتمرات وحدها ،
فمن غير المتوقع أن تعود في أي وقت
قريبًا ، لن تكون النوادي الليلية هنا حفلات موسيقية في
معظم العروض ، لكننا ما زلنا
نعتقد أنه سيكون لدينا تجربة رائعة مع
بعض أكبر الاختلافات  في
المدينة في طوابق الكازينو حيث تكون
الصحة العامة ذات أهمية قصوى ،
ستجد عددًا أقل من الأشخاص يتزاحمون حول
طاولات الكرابس وأرضيات ماكينات القمار
التي سيتم إعادة تشكيلها للسماح
بالتباعد الاجتماعي من الواضح أننا على مر
السنين تطورنا إلى تجربة أوسع
بكثير من  فقط في أرضية الكازينو
وهي فرصة للناس
ليأتوا ويحصلوا على
تجربة أكثر خصوصية وأكثر حميمية ،
ولا بأس بحشد أصغر مع
المدير العام لبيني تشو تيما لمطعم لوتس أوف سيام البالغ من العمر 21 عامًا ،
ما هي
توقعاتك للزوجين المقبلين  الأشهر التي
قالتها مي إلى جانب عائلتي
وموظفيي هي أنك تعلم أن عام 2020
ليس الوقت المناسب لنا لتحقيق الربح ،
إنه مجرد البقاء على قيد الحياة في هذا  النقطة
أنها سيئة للغاية ، فلا شك في
أن هذا الوباء سيغير لاس فيجاس
على المدى القصير ، ولكن قد تكون
فيجاس أيضًا فرصة رئيسية لاظهار
جانب مختلف تمامًا من المدينة ،
وأعتقد أن هناك بعض الأشياء في لاس
فيجاس كثيرًا  من الناس لا يعرفون
أننا محاطون بالمنتزهات الوطنية ،
فهناك الكثير من الأنشطة الخارجية ، هناك
جبال ، على الرغم من أنها قد تكون
120 في الخارج هنا في الخمسينيات والستينيات ، فإنني
أعني أنك ستقضي
وقتًا ممتعًا في حياتك  إن مستوى الراحة هو
حقًا يتعلق بانفتاحك
للبحث عن شيء خاص هنا في فيجاس
إذا كنت تحلم بقضاء عطلة على الشاطئ ، تعمل
المدن الساحلية في جميع أنحاء
إسبانيا لوقت إضافي لإثبات قدرتها على الحفاظ على
سلامة الزوار ولكنها لن تكون كذلك  بسيطة
مثل وضع بطانية الشاطئ الخاصة بك في
كندا وتقديم العطاءات الجيدة على
ساحل البحر الأبيض المتوسط بإسبانيا ، يتم وضع شبكة في
لرمال لتخصيص تسعة أمتار مربعة لل
وار ، وسيحتاج رواد الشاطئ إل
حجز مساحة على  للحصول على
إمكانية الوصول مع أوقات الوصول المحددة ، فإن
عدم الكشف عن هويته يقول رئيس البلدية اليوم إن
الحياة الطبيعية الجديدة تجلب شواطئ جديدة
سوف نتكيف معها ، وسوف نحاول الاستمتاع
بها بأفضل طريقة ممكنة كما يقول في
عرض سانشيز على ساحل المحيط الأطلسي ، يخطط رئيس البلدية
لإعادة فتحه.  مع نظام شبكي مشابه
وسعة قصوى تصل إلى 2300 من
مرتادي الشواطئ يوميًا أي أقل من 75 في
المائة من فصول الصيف السابقة ، يقول
إنها خطة ستحافظ على
مسافة الأمان بين الأشخاص الذين يأتون
للاستمتاع بالشاطئ في جميع
غرف تغيير الشواطئ الإسبانية والحمامات.
تخضع للتطهير الصارم باستخدام
كراسي استلقاء للتشمس ومظلات ذات سعة محدودة ،
وسيتعين تنظيفها على
فترات منتظمة وإبقائها على مسافة مترين على الأقل
بالنسبة للسكان المحليين ، وستكون القواعد الجديدة
تستحق العناء إذا كان من الممكن أن تساعد في
إنعاش الاقتصاد الصيفي ، فهذا يعتمد
على عددهم  الناس يأتون إلى الشاطئ
يخبرنا هذا الرجل إذا استمر الأمر كما هو
الآن فقط للمقيمين ، فلن يكون ذلك
ضروريًا ولكن إذا جاء السياح
والأشخاص من الخارج ، فأنا  أعتقد أنها ستكون
فكرة جيدة يقول رئيس الوزراء إنه
يريد أن يجعل إسبانيا الوجهة الأكثر أمانًا لقضاء
العطلات في أوروبا وهذا هو السبب في أن
البلاد ترفع تدريجياً
قيود فيروس كورونا هذه الفكرة
هي ضمان الصحة والسلامة
بقدر ما تكون نقطة بيع.  إسبانيا شمس
بحر ورمال
أتيكا شوبرت سي إن إن مايوركا إسبانيا